ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
program I don't love how much I'm
hearing the term martial law I don't
love that tell you that much you're
hearing it a lot now gavin newsom
governor of california brought it up
hearing it the press is bringing it up
when you hear something like that over
and over again it feels like they're
doing a soft launch for martial law you
know feels like they're just do it a
little roll out see how you see how you
react to the idea you can't do things
like that all at once because it
inspires widespread panic and chaos
suspending the Constitution and bringing
in the military that tends to make
people a little iffy so what they do I
think is they introduce you to the
concept little by little a little
shelter in place a little shutdown and
we start seeing people at public parks
people working out people doing things
people still gathering together in
groups and the government goes you know
I don't know if we're gonna be able to
weather the storm here without the tank
we might need the tank to come in and
stop you from gathering in a park you
know I'm no fan of martial law I do
understand the shelter in place you know
and what I want to criticize the
conspiracy community for saying that the
virus isn't real or the virus is just
the flu or the virus is a cover so that
the government can arrest Tom Hanks what
I what I do fully understand and am
quite aware of is that when you have a
problem like this like 9/11 which is so
big and new that you are going to have
elements of the government and the
private sector you're going to have
people you know asrama might as Rahm
emanuelle said he was the chief of staff
for Barack Obama and who is now the
mayor of Chicago or was I believe he
still is the mayor of Chicago as he said
never let a crisis go to waste so there
are going to be people that try to take
the few remaining rights you have so you
have to be a little vigilant that
doesn't mean you go COFF down an old
person's throat does it mean you know
you ignore what's a clear reality which
is this is a you know incredibly
dangerous virus but it means you're
vigilant and you understand that no
government has ever emerged from a
crisis with less power doesn't happen
doesn't happen
the government now is growing in power
it's going to start to pay you to live
to stay home to sit in your house it's
gonna cut you a check yet you don't have
and by the way I'm for that people need
that but just let's think about this
let's zoom out for a little bit and when
we look at this we go.you are now
dependent on the government for
everything for everything they've taken
your ability in the short term to earn a
living and we understand that in the
short term I understand the need to
close things and I've told people to
comply with this but there does come a
point where you're going to see you know
it's kind of like when you bring a car
in to a mechanic and the mechanic is
less than reputable and you know they're
like it's totaled you know we just we go
we totaled out the car you know you
bring it in you know because you have
headlights out and they look good
you might as well we're totaling the
economy right now the world economy I
mean we are totaling the world economy
we are seeing a global depression take
root we are seeing potentially
unemployment in the range of 20%
containment has failed the reports now
out of New York and California if you
have symptoms do not get tested unless
you are in a very high-risk group and
you're so sick that you have to go to
the hospital they are saving the tests
for health care workers doctors nurses
first responders people that are coming
in contact with this virus and with sick
people all the time so could at that
point when you say testing we can't test
anybody the containment model which is
based on knowing who has this and who
doesn't you know trying to contain it
you know the social distancing the
shelter in place you know all of that
you know might have some positive effect
hopefully it does but a lot of people
are skeptical at this point about how
much of a positive effect it will have
we should still do it we should still do
it for the time being but I think a lot
of people are saying you got to move
into mitigation which is basically the
development the rapid development of
antiviral drugs you know they're talking
about chloroquine or something I think I
believe that's the name that was used to
fight malaria but I was reading about
those the side-effects on that last
night it could be blindness and if you
take an extra dose sudden death you got
it yeah chloroquine yeah if you take a
sudden if you take an extra dose of that
goodbye so I don't know if that's the
best idea to give to old people I
imagine that that'll be given to them in
a hospital you take that with
erythromycin which is the z-pak to get
bronchitis you take a z-pak
with from iesson take the five day you
know to on the first day and then boom
boo-boom boo-boom and it usually clears
bronchitis so if you take the
chloroquine on for malaria and the
erythromycin it is beating back the
virus I have a friend who's a doctor at
Lenox Hill Hospital who said actually
the results are pretty good does it mean
you know Trump gets high marks here this
is you know it's a colossal failure it's
a colossal failure to not have the tests
to not order more supplies in January
and February when you had the
intelligence community warning you about
this when you were you didn't have to
have the intelligence community warning
you about it because you're watching it
happen in another country it's a
tremendous failure it's a fireable
offense whether you love the guy hate
the guy it's a fireable offense because
it was done correctly in other countries
I mean you know South Korea and again I
have no emotion here with this I'm just
telling you south I'm not South Korea
but yeah South Korea but Taiwan you know
24 million people one death 85 cases
that was up until recently and I'm sure
their numbers are pretty similar to 153
cases and four deaths there you go or
two deaths
yeah that's Taiwan they're right next to
China but they had been through SARS
they knew what this was gonna look like
they got the masks immediately they
ordered the supplies they made testing
widely available it's a high-tech health
service they have where you get the
results to your phone they text you the
results you know exactly where you stand
and if you have to go quarantine so [ __ ]
I don't care how much you love this guy
and how much you think he is essential
or whatever fairy tale you've concocted
in your head about any of these people
any of our leaders that you love so much
yet have never met I mean all of these
people would want nothing to do with you
the Obamas the Trump's they wouldn't
want anything to do with you can you
imagine your disgusting family your
marinara sauce covered fingers do you
understand the way these people [ __ ]
look at you when will you when do you
think you people will wake up is it when
you're all in camps I mean truly at what
point do you understand that these
people [ __ ] look at you like a
[ __ ] rat scurrying across a busy
street they're puzzled by you they're
confused almost they watch you run
across the street and if you make it
they go huh and if you get hit by a car
and you get squashed in the middle of
the street they go ha ha
they don't necessarily rejoice but it
doesn't [ __ ] up their day at all I think
we all need to grow up now I really
believe that I think if we don't grow up
we're gonna be in trouble as a species
and if we keep thinking that these
people give a [ __ ] about us and that
they care about us on any level at all
we're going to we're going to delude
ourselves to death and I think it's a
big [ __ ] problem and I don't care
whether it's aoc any of the people that
we've elected to be the narcissist of
the week and to tell us all how we live
how to live all of these people are
after for the most part their own power
and they're not really looking out for
you they believe things in the abstract
that could help you but when Bernie
Sanders who I like and respect you know
treats Joe Biden like a statesman in
that debate instead of turning around
and going you are the [ __ ] problem
how did Trump get elected by going to
Jeb Bush and destroying his own party
Trump destroyed the Republicans he
destroyed the bush dynasty they they
limped Jeb limped out of those debates
that young Bush still can't get elected
in Texas the little kid tried in a
congressional race the the the damage
done to that name might be irreparable
and they were the biggest pull it one of
the biggest political dynasties in our
country and Trump got rid of him and he
did that by being rude I mean he did
that by saying things that made you go
whoa but you have Bernie Sanders kind of
treating chill by didn't like a
statesman cuz they're friends or
whatever
Trump was friends with Hillary he didn't
care he didn't care they were friends he
played golf with Bill they you know he
went to a wedding he went to their wet
lake they they came to his wedding he
was friends with them it didn't matter
didn't matter to him and yeah you know
maybe Sanders has more integrity great
that doesn't win that doesn't win it's
very hard to root for the left because
they they're so allergic to winning they
are so they are born losers they are
incapable of [ __ ] winning I mean
Trump may still win the next election
how hilarious is that we have a
worldwide preventable pandemic in this
country a stock market crash the likes
which we haven't seen in a generation
and we're going into a global depression
and Trump may still win he might pull it
out he the record he has to run on is
the worst record of any maybe president
ever I mean has anyone the wholesale
destruction of the American economy and
our complete way of life we can't leave
our houses we owe the whole country got
suspended and he still could pull it out
does that give you an idea of how
pathetic the other side is how they're
quibbling and they're in fight
is so repulsive they're so annoying to
most people even me who realizes and has
realized a trump again is a hawkster
he's peddling his wares to people that
you know see him as some type of avatar
but but essentially he's a huckster if
you don't see that even if you think
he's funny even if you hate the other
side you see Trump as a huckster I think
the difference is that a lot of people
out there go yeah but he's our hawkster
he's my like he's he's ripping off
everybody on behalf of us if that were
only the case if that were only the case
I could be like great but you can't
leave your house cuz we didn't order the
tests and the masks cuz he didn't care
she didn't want to spook the stock
market by even talking about a pandemic
you know because it didn't matter
because everything was good the gravy
train was rolling along and you know so
again it's a mistake if you if you're
unwilling to admit that you're you've
left the realm of logic and fine if you
want to dwell in your own world that you
create and I think that that is where
you know we're seeing these states like
Philadelphia I'm sorry cities like
Philadelphia saying we're not going to
prosecute we're not going to arrest and
jail people for crimes petty crimes and
they you know petty to them when you
read the list includes burglary auto
theft vandalism property crime so I mean
what's gonna start to happen in in
Philadelphia and cities across the
country that are unable to deal with the
increased spike in crime that is almost
certain to happen with it kind of goes
along with the destruction of the
American economy
a rise in crime 20% unemployment they're
talking what you're going to see in
cities like that is
to throw their hands up but they're
gonna wait for the federal government to
roll the tanks in they're gonna say
listen we don't have the resources to
handle this bring in the tanks and
that's why you're hearing the term
martial law the states are not going to
be able to handle this especially in
high crime areas where the crime is
going to explode the country folks does
not look the same after this not trying
to be alarmist here but it doesn't look
the same it does not emerge in the same
way you're going to see the rich and
they've already done it they're fleeing
to the Hamptons to Martha's Vineyard
they're going behind gates they know
they knew before this happened probably
they had a inkling that something was
coming I mean I know there's a very
wealthy guy in New York who's close to a
billionaire and I know somebody very
close to him and this guy was told in
February that he would maybe not have to
pay rent on some of his properties his
commercial establishments and he should
get out of the market or reduce his
positions in the market this was you
know several senators are claiming of
course that they did not you know sell
these stocks or change their positions
because of inside information that's a
complete lie they should be hung I mean
it's as close to treason as I can think
about somebody profiting off the deaths
of their fellow countrymen and and not
informing anybody that this was going to
happen and certainly not doing anything
from their position of power in the
government to reduce the likelihood it
would happen just going in there and
profiting from it it's disgusting
now all the Republicans in the beginning
it was like one guy should resign but
then he found out that all the Senators
did it and four of them were Republicans
and everybody's like well maybe this one
guy should resign because didn't want to
lose control of the Senate but this is
you know
pretty disgusting if you fall on a
partisan if you're still thinking in
terms of left-to-right Republican or
Democrat in this period of time you're
wrong you're wrong and I feel bad for
you because you're gonna step on your
throat it has nothing to do with the
blue or red a Republican or Democrat
left or right that is a show this is a
show okay the people that then have
money and power right now are going to
get richer they're gonna get more
powerful and they're gonna leave you and
your family to starve this is absolutely
the case it's happening already and if
you're still thinking that will half of
them give a [ __ ] about you I mean God
what would do it folks
do they have to FaceTime you and tell
you how much they don't give a [ __ ] do
you do they have to FaceTime you and go
hi mr. and mrs. who is this is this the
UH fan toesies sister Miller's Sister
Dominic's
is this the Parkers Hey
we just want to call you up and let you
know you're on your own here did you not
did you not get that did you not see
that with all the int you know with us
selling our stock did you can we stop
doing the [ __ ] press conferences to
who who are they who is feeling better
after that that little doctor Fowey
who's probably a good do but he's a tiny
little man
we have no there is no time for short
people right now sorry
nobody's being made to feel better by a
tiny little doctor give me somebody six
[ __ ] two who looks like they could
take this thing on little foutch he
looks like coronavirus he's a tiny
little man nobody feels good about that
at this moment sure people are great in
good times but when times are tough you
want to look at somebody tall to lead
you through who sees above the crowd who
is this woman who comes out in a night
dress who looks like she's on percocet
who's it's just like my daughter's
my daughter Stuart you have two
beautiful millennial daughters they're
the most important generation
Millennials I have two daughters it's
like who the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] who is
this and then you have Trump and then
pence stone-faced in the back and then
of course they bring out you know Pompeo
who just wants to be you know the
secretary of state who used to run the
CIA and what he just wants to be just
sitting eating a French Dip sandwich
that poor guys like what the [ __ ] is
this I thought we were just blackmailing
people taking photos of them [ __ ]
underaged people why it's pandemic
they're wholly unprepared and the
country is unprepared for what's about
to happen
there's no way to be prepared for what's
about to happen what's about to happen
is going to be truly astounding for a
lot of people cities are going to turn
pretty quickly into Mad Max situations
there's going to be shortages there's
going to be an increase in crime they're
probably going to declare martial law
some version of that I don't see in
certain areas the country I don't see
how that doesn't happen it seems
inevitable that if things continue the
way they are continuing all the big
finance people the Goldman Sachs guys
are all being told it's an 18-month
pandemic with waves of sick people
waves of where we can all go back to
work I'm sure that looks great by the
way I'm sure everybody's really except
like you know ways where we have to shut
down again it's just going to be
cyclical and when we all go back to work
it's I don't think it's gonna be boom
times I got to be honest with you I
don't think it's gonna quite feel the
same I think people are still going to
be like you know what are we doing there
think long and hard about where they go
how they spend their money
what risk they're willing to take what
level of risk they're willing to take
concert comedy show restaurant you know
beach these are all different things
we're all gonna know people who pass
away
tragically from this disease it's gonna
be emotionally scarring it's gonna
damage the psyche of people not only
individually but the country psyche and
I think unfortunately the reality of how
bad things are is gonna push people
further into their own world it's gonna
push them further into conspiracy
further into you know cults religion
things that give people some level of
hope or at least a way to organize the
world and it's gonna get bad and I think
that when people confronted with chaos
they need something and I think for the
good of the country it has to be this
show it has to be the patreon the Tim
Dylan show it has to be the merch I
don't think it can be anything else
I I worry about you being taken in by
charlatans out there online there's a
lot of there's a lot of problems there's
a lot of bad actors in the digital space
just waiting for you come here come here
we're giving you the information we're
giving you the perspective I don't want
to be hopeless there are good things
coming celebrities and politicians will
die that's nice that will be
fun to see and watch if we are still
alive to watch that happen that will be
amusing good things are going to come of
this
I'm telling you real housewives are
going to die that will be fun for all of
us from what I see the disease clearly
does not discriminate so there's going
to be some annoying people that are
gonna get it and they're gonna go
bye-bye
and that might keep us sane for a little
while because good people are gonna go
people you love are gonna go people you
respect are gonna go but then other
people are gonna go too it's the little
things it's the small victories that you
can't lose sight of in these times you
should put pictures on your wall of
people you hope get it and when one of
them does put a check have a drink eat a
good meal um of course joking about
celebrating the deaths of others but am
i and how bad will it get were we need
some form of entertainment as cryptic as
that sounds as depressing as that may be
as inhumane as you might find that to be
we're going to me light at the end of
the tunnel and it is not going to come
from the powers that be they are not
going to help you your community might
help you your friends and your family
might help you your your local
government could help you the powers
that be are going to make a mad dash for
the hills they're gonna grab their money
and their families and they're gonna
[ __ ] there
they head out to the lifeboats it's
going to happen this isn't this isn't a
debate this isn't left or right don't
look for these people to show you a way
out of this [ __ ] mass it's not gonna
happen
comedians get off Instagram live for the
love of God especially unsuccessful ones
especially ones that failed at the real
thing
ones that couldn't do it when you had a
stage and an audience
get the [ __ ] off Instagram live nobody
wants your thoughts now enough comedy
couldn't be less essential funny yes
funny we all need funny comedy no the
entertainment business is about to get
gutted if you are in the business and
you've done well enough you'll probably
make it through if you survive but your
relationships are going to change your
business relationships are gonna change
how you do business is gonna change how
you attract a following is gonna change
how you make money that this business is
gonna change it's absolutely going to
change if you're independent the only
way out of this is being self-sufficient
you cannot rely on anybody anymore for
anything when this is particularly aimed
to people in creative fields
you're not the the the sitcom [ __ ]
the pilot you thought you were gonna get
the tour you were going on I mean
everything unfortunately you know is
sand through the hourglass it's [ __ ]
all you can do right now is have
something valuable for other people and
find a way to deliver it to them and
that is not
going on Instagram live with you to act
with you stand up back for the love of
Christ Jesus Christ does anyone right
now want to see a half-decent comedian
perform to an empty room
what psychopath wants that who are you
all performing for it's over it's Oh
what the [ __ ] do you think happens next
you get noticed on Instagram live and
then what what happens then they lead
you with a mask through the gates of
paramount studios it's curtains collect
your belongings and go checkout is at
11:00 a.m. there is no late check-out
today the rooms are bought get the [ __ ]
out the vacation has ended your
meaningless life is no longer public
consumption go back put your privacy
settings go reestablish some
relationship that matters before it all
goes black some of the things I've seen
have been good but the majority the
majority of them have not and I feel for
people oh it's not so easy to do what
Logan Paul does is it you all thought
you were slick and you [ __ ] it on
youtubers and now you're all trying to
be youtubers as the jib
see in thinner the Stephen King movie
said die clean - I clean - I clean white
boy that's what he said some of you have
no clue what's coming because you trust
the government and the media because
your children or you're insane they know
things we don't know they're trying to
avoid widespread panic they're trying to
avoid chaos they know this is a lot
worse than they're even letting on they
know maybe this thing's mutated who
knows
take it out people left and right and
there doesn't seem to be a rhyme or
reason why maybe it's just this a novel
virus we don't have immunity people's
system some can handle it some can't but
how terrifying is that that is why
they're like well it's mainly elderly
people you know Mike Pence said the
other day he goes the majority of
Americans don't need to worry about
getting this there's nope there's no
statistics to back that up
there's none what the ones out of China
it'll either 2,000 people a day are
dying that's Spanish flu China we don't
know what the [ __ ] going on you can't
trust the media so we have the vice
president going yeah most people don't
have anything to worry about when
contracting this disease there are no
numbers to support that we don't know
that that's the case we don't know
what's the death toll in Italy right now
4825 yeah a lot of dead people yesterday
there was 793 and it's not over I know
you know if we if we if we were closing
the book on people go four thousand so
what I don't know anybody will
coronavirus do you know how many people
died your gunshot wounds you know how
many people died of other things like
the flu is it over we're just beginning
the movie has just started we're barely
through the previews you don't know
what's coming we don't need
a lot of people to die to unleash
martial law and to doom the economy you
don't need a lot of people to die to
collapse the health care system you
don't but I do think you're good to see
sadly a lot more people die I mean what
are the debt what are the totals right
now we usually do the totals in the
beginning but let's do them now 301
627,000 so we just passed the 300
thousand mark and then the - 300
thousand worldwide yeah the desks are
about to hit thirteen thousand were at
twelve thousand nine hundred fifty five
America what are the totals in America
in the USA we have wouldn't be funny if
looking at an old time rock DJ like
there was this guy cousin Brucie 101.1
when I was growing up was like like that
type of old school anybody hey it's
cousin Brucie just be funny if like in
the dystopian nightmare that we live in
he's like hey baby it's cousin Brucie
giving you the totals giving you the
totals we got about 23,000 deaths right
now
now how about rocking out to the Four
Seasons where are we in America we have
twenty two thousand eight hundred
thirteen cases and two hundred eighty
eight Tests I can't wait for coronavirus
the musical coronavirus the musical can
you see it Broadway stage opens twenty
twenty-three people are standing there
it's kind of like rent if you remember
rent the stage is you know there's no
real set there's just some garbage cans
and stuff and you know there's a catwalk
and it's kind of plain and there's just
like people standing on the stage and
you know 20 23 coronavirus musical you
know the first number everybody's
standing there just like you know
they're doing it on the beat do Lu Doo
Lu
uh-uh what was that what was that I
heard about a pandemic happening what
was that Wu Han China what was that
pandemic bat flew plague playing in
about flu and then you know I mean it's
coming it's coming
where are the tests we thought we had
the tests just doctors and nurses
singing by the way isn't the worst thing
about this that we have to treat doctors
and nurses with reverence and respect
is there anybody more annoying than
doctors and nurses let's be honest I
mean I know that now they're essential
but I wish they weren't I wish we were
lying on like blackjack dealers or
people that I like doctors and nurses
they're almost as bad as teachers
imagine if we had to imagine if we all
had to glorify teachers during this oh
my god I would just go kill me now
I do like I do you know it's just
doctors or vet you know they're pompous
doctors are pompous and nurses as well
think they're doctors it's not all of
them but it's a fair amount of them and
many people in the medical field agree
with me I'm just saying I wish we were
relying on another group that we had to
exalt you know I don't know who you know
people that work at clam bars like fat
women ladle clam chowder no a cop I wish
they were the front lines and we could
be like yeah I support I support Donna I
mean you know folks you have to remember
when all this is happening that you're
living through a historic time I love
that isn't that people tell you that
like it's a good thing you're living
through a historic time this is historic
this is a historic time it is a historic
time you know so was the Holocaust was
historic you think they walked around
Auschwitz ago you know what we have to
remember we're living in a historic time
we really are we just get to see it all
up close you think they talked about
that probably not but what do I know
you know I'm itching I'm itching to get
out there and do live stand-up comedy
again but it's just not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen for a while
and even when it does happen who the
[ __ ] knows what its gonna look like
you know what's Billy Eilish up - she
was on tour - google it news on Billy
Idol what's she doing she always wore
that mask anyway she was prepared
remember she always had that bane mask
on her face what's she up to
I mean she it looks like she's just on
The Voice right now The Voice battle
rounds Billy Eilish Whitney Houston more
songs and pairings I mean to put Billy
Eilish at Whitney Houston in the same
sentence I mean imagine what a decaying
society we are how deserving are we of a
plague to put the toast - Whitney
Houston one of the greatest voices ever
we did exactly what a musician should do
entertain the [ __ ] out of us and then
died in the tub didn't stick around for
too long well isn't the voice people
covering stuff who knows but that's
probably not that recent they shut says
one day ago really yeah but didn't they
shut down the production of all of these
shows I guess they shot him so long ago
yeah that's the other thing that Jimmy
Fallon's doing the Tonight Show from his
house the view you know Whoopi
Goldberg's like skyping in interview
enough I mean I don't want to you know I
don't want to be the bringer of bad news
but just shut it down I mean are we
gonna be living into martial law and
still watching Jimmy Fallon is that
what's gonna happen here are we gonna be
living under martial law and still
watching carpool karaoke shut it down
have the decency to treat us like real
dictators and just have state TV which
is what that is by the way Fallon and
coordinated state TV I mean am I gonna
look out my window
see it tank rolling down the street and
then turn on my TV and see Ellen dancing
at what from her living room at what
point do these people just go the [ __ ]
home and stay there turn off the webcam
and let us all be let us be please give
us a few months without you I mean I
mean can you imagine it Jimmy Fallon
going outside Ellen
dancing with the military Jimmy Fallon
taking pictures with the tank it's
parked at the end of his block I mean at
what point can we just can we can we
request that they shut the entertainment
industry off shut it off there should be
martial law on Instagram you should have
to get approval for the military it's a
post that's what should happen that
[ __ ] me up they wouldn't give me any
[ __ ] we'd have to go onto the dark
web we'd have to livestream on the dark
web is that that does anyone ever do
that no I mean that's what a red room is
supposed to be yeah that's not real it's
not real that's what America is about to
become by the way a red room supposedly
where you torture and kill people the
people in the comments are like kill
them his leg so it's like there's a
torture chamber and you get to say what
you want done to the person if you
donate money like a super chat on
YouTube get his leg pin his leg back
it's like not real but who knows
who knows what entertainment will be
considered after this every company in
this country right now should be making
ventilators everybody is some of them
are to their credit every [ __ ]
company should be mahogany oz whoever
make [ __ ] ventilators you're gonna
need a lot of ventilators you're gonna
need masks make [ __ ] masks you know
they should have been happening months
ago you know what good is it to call
yourself the greatest country in the
world and they get beaten by Taiwan at
survival you know how does that happen
how does it happen they all you do is
call yourself you pat yourself on the
back for being the greatest country in
the world
Taiwan figures out a way to do it you
can't Taiwan I mean that's amazing to me
it's amazing they are strong and
virulent like nationalism is if they're
still people walking around be like I
love this country relatives are dead in
the street I love this country I love
that I can't get tested for this thing I
may or may not have it's a death wish
large segment of the population in this
country wants to die they want to die
they were brought up thinking that the
glory would come after they died that
this life was at me rehearsal for the
next one this is what religion pounds
into the heads of people well they're
still kids and that's why many of those
people grow up and they keep that belief
and they treat their bodies and
everything else like [ __ ] and they don't
care because as soon as you know as soon
as they have the glorious aneurysm or
heart attack you know and they fall on
the floor Denny's that's when things get
good that's when things get good that's
what it gets fun a friend our friend is
calling it was it Alex I will say this
you know I really truly every day get up
ago should I get the [ __ ] out of Los
Angeles should I get the [ __ ] out of
terminator should I get the hell out of
here and I don't know I don't know I
believe that I don't think anywhere is
gonna be safe truly if it goes as bad as
it could and will go potentially
what'll save us is some antivirals
chloroquine ein little REM des aveer
perhaps perhaps that becomes essential
the erythromycin and the chloroquine and
i hope it works i hope it works
but i mean and then we will then with
then we have a where's Joe Biden by the
way where is Joe Biden has Joe Biden
he's running for the Presidency he's
running for the highest office in the
land he's disappeared he sees his
handlers are keeping him out of the
spotlight because they know he'll will
make a mess of this I mean I had a joke
of my actor I said the Trump Biden
debate is a debate where we don't need a
country anymore we squeeze we call China
like a kid at a sleepover that's not
working out and calls his parents
because hey come now just come now leave
now I'm ready now we're ready now there
are people saying they're getting out of
the Chinese quarantine and Americans
living in China expats and who knows if
they're writing these you know updates
with a gun to their head things are
better the bright futures ahead you know
they just got a guy with a gun in your
head you're sitting in the room staring
at Chairman Mao's photo on the wall
you're just typing they just come in
with a laptop MacBook sit it down and go
tell everybody how good it is
tell everyone outside how much fun we're
all having this has been fun he says
that they take your temperature
everywhere now that might be the future
infrared technology in order to get into
an event you might not be able to get
into an event with a fever anymore it's
interesting if you have a fever if
you're feverish if you're over a hundred
they might just say you're not getting
into this concert you're not coming in
it's interesting that might be the
future the future I mean the I mean
Whitney Cummings was telling me she was
going back from New York to LA and the
flight she said was full no one spoke to
each other everybody was wiping down the
plane there was no service
the flight attendants did not speak to
them and the pilot did not make any
announcements it was like a crazy flight
it was amazing you know when I heard
that I was like what a [ __ ] amazing
thing to to go through to
because I've flown so many times and
that has never been the case
you know III imagine even after 9/11
they made comments and they talked to
you but right now the level of fear is
so high that nobody you know there was
no communication between the flight
attendants the pilot and the passengers
on the plane everybody was just sitting
there you know wheels up six and a half
hour flight wheels down and then get off
the plane and run it the future doesn't
look like the past dead especially in
the in the in the way you know I was
while I'm watching these shows on
Netflix is this good show called
restaurants on the edge and where they
just go to restaurants that are in
beautiful locations but are failing
because the food sucks they're poorly
designed and what happens is Netflix
goes three people go they have a
designer a restaurateur in a chef they
help redesign the menu they help
redesign the restaurant and you know you
know obviously all these restaurants
probably still fail because the idiots
as soon as the Netflix team leaves they
go back to doing it their way you know
now although this actually you know and
then the free you know is whatever but
I'm watching these chefs walk through
these open-air markets to buy produce
and to buy and there's fish and you know
fowl you know birds and there's all
kinds of things and you're seeing
yourself you know obviously that is the
reality for most of the world is these
you know wet markets these markets we're
live animals are sold you know and the
people walk through them and they take
photos I mean are you gonna I mean does
that continue are you gonna go walk
through those markets anymore you're
gonna try something in one of those
markets somebody hands you a piece of
fruit I mean not that it's any better
here I'm not I'm not an idiot I know
that things sitting in a supermarket or
is likely to make you sick is anything
but just the idea of walking through a
market you see live animals you see that
like is that are you gonna do that you
get
ooh you know you're gonna go on a cruise
are you gonna go on a cruise right now
are you gonna eat it buffets are you
gonna do all that stuff is that does
that survive do those things survive a
pandemic probably people got to go
somewhere to be disgusting animals but I
mean you know travel does travel take a
hit two people go I'm good I'm good or
do people just say [ __ ] I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go anyway I don't care that
becomes a real question is what does a
world look like I'm talking best case
because worst case forget it I mean
we've already went through that we're
talking martial law we're talking crime
we're talking the cities are abandoned
we're talking to rich fleeted their
bunkers and that all looks to be the
case but let's imagine we get on the
other side of the outer the effects of
that somehow miraculously don't
materialize fully on the other side of
that you know are you allowed into an
arena with a fever going forward if it
is an eighteen-month pandemic that's
cyclical where there's waves of sick
people are you allowed into a restaurant
with a fever are you allowed into a
movie theater with a fever
fascinating [ __ ] to think about how does
life change and then we get into the
scary stuff and you know what that is
the chips the bio the bio security stuff
you know do we do they put a chip in yes
you they know how sick you are and if
they don't like your behavior do they
just deactivate the chip just deactivate
yeah I mean that's been those nano chips
the idea of putting that under your skin
was so that they had all your health
information so that now in a world we
anyone trusted the government it's
really not a bad idea on its face like
if you collapse in a Walmart and they
come up to you and there's a chip that
says this guy's diabetic he's this he's
that he's got this he's got that and
they don't have to wait to find all that
information out so you either regain
consciousness or they can get your
relatives on the phone the idea that
that's all in a in a you know there's a
convenient
stare but then how but but Jesus Christ
how much are you giving up for that how
much are you giving up for that giving
all of your medical information to a
government and letting them install a
chip in you
and then trusting that they can't do
horrible things to you with you no
because they have access to that chip
again on his face great idea it's an
idea that's like you know but that's
that's what comes down the pike
what biotech firms right now are
developing different types of you know
diagnostic tools for concert venues
arenas sporting events what restaurants
public places resorts amusement parks
what biotech firms are gonna go out
there and start thinking about how to
you know and maybe it's short term maybe
it's long term maybe it's forever but if
it is an 18 month pandemic with waves of
things and you are and you have it you
know you're a property that's insured
and your insurance company is my company
Hugo you need to figure out a way to
prevent sick people from coming in here
you know we got to insulate ourselves
against the liability we got a it's
fascinating it's very interesting to
think about you know but another thing
to think about is when you are in
quarantine is your penis hard if your
penis is not hard you cannot have sex
many of us are not having sex if you're
not in a relationship it's hard right
now to get somebody over there are
people who come over and [ __ ] you but I
mean again you know you take the
temperature first
you know it's chewable and it's got all
the good ingredients in there that keep
the dick nice and hard okay you get it
online it's easy it's discreet it's
shipped and discreet packaging they're
shipping right now even during the
pandemic they know that you have needs
your partner's needs and they're gonna
give you blue chew it is a great
fast-acting supplement that allows you
to perform in the bedroom
this may be your last [ __ ] make it good
make it good
who wants a soft dick in the end times
nobody you need to be out there slinging
hard dick during the apocalypse I got
that apocalyptic [ __ ] ladies I'm
slinging hard dick during the apocalypse
I mean why not blue shoe calm slash Tim
promo code 10 promo code Tim T I am what
are they doing for is 5% off no you just
pay five dollars shipping and you get
your first shipment free $5 shipping the
first shipment is free you don't have to
pay anything $5 shipping their so
convinced that this product is going to
change your life that they're giving it
to you free because they know you're
gonna re-up
you're gonna re-up because it works it
does work it's safe it's tested I don't
know who tested it but someone are the
FDA the FDA Food and Drug Administration
telling you right now this is the good
stuff
blue chew great way to support the show
if you like the content the
entertainment that we provide and you
need a hard deck this is a great way to
do it by using the promo code Tim you
get a free shipment and you only pay $5
shipping
I mean who loses there nobody literally
nobody we're we're going through some
changes here the studio we're going to
we're going to modernize the studio
broadcasting has become is the future
right here this is the reality we talked
about this the other night since live
stand-up has been put on hold
indefinitely we are going to modernize
the studio we're gonna get a we're gonna
get an icepick television in here we're
gonna be able to pull up media in
lifetime I'm in real-time whatever we're
going to be able to bring you a better
show especially now it's super important
that
we are able to you know not only have
some fun but get out you know
information or kind of we all need to
stay on top of what the [ __ ] going on
you know so we're gonna be able to you
know interview people on skype and we're
gonna be able to pull up articles and
pull up videos and things like that and
that's coming down the pike and we
appreciate that we also appreciate oh
this one too huh Oh we'll do that at the
very end that ones audio only you two
will get mad if we do that so the
studio's going to we appreciate
everybody that's that's contributing on
patreon we know that everybody is in a
bad spot right now most people are in a
bad spot we know you don't have a lot of
[ __ ] money and that's why we're
trying to put out as much free content
as possible a lot of these free podcasts
on our youtube you know channel we also
put out videos and everything on
Instagram Twitter Tim Jay Dylan TI ll o
in on Instagram and Twitter and all the
content and this podcast will always be
free you'll always get one podcast a
week free you'll always get a youtube
one or two youtubes you know either an
extra episode and then also a live
stream that we do where you can ask
questions all of those things are always
gonna be free the only thing you'll ever
have to pay for is if you want the
patreon episodes and they're there's a
lot of archives there there's like you
know 177 the archived episodes 170 hours
of content you can sift through and a
lot of interesting interviews with a lot
of people and you know it's a it's for
$5 a month it's a pretty good deal but I
totally get it if you don't have it and
you know if you don't have it we're
still pumping out a lot of free stuff
don't worry about it you know we want
you to get yourself right most important
thing is for you to be financially okay
during this thing we're gonna try to
figure out the best way to start
donating some money to people or
organizations I spoke to Andrew Schultz
about it right now a lot of us are
focusing on people that have been
directly affected that in our industry
so waiters and waitresses at comedy
clubs are [ __ ] right now
and those are the people that allowed us
to earn a living being comedians you
know they were the support staff they
brought you drinks they brought you food
and they helped those operations run
they made those operations run so we're
helping those people now but of course
the scope of that you know it's gonna
get bigger we're gonna look for other
ways to you know contribute money to
people in real time that need it whether
it's food banks or stuff like that
because things are gonna get ugly and
they are getting it bad and if you do
have money and you do have the
wherewithal to kind of give people you
know you can't volunteer right now
nobody wants you to leave your [ __ ]
house so the reality is if you do have
the money the money helps that's kind of
gonna be but I am also very careful
about where you give money because
there's a lot of institutions out there
that misuse funds and misuse money so
we're all gonna have to figure out
together how exactly we go forward with
that I'm speaking of some other
comedians you know I rogue and a bunch
of people that are you know you know
that help a lot of different people but
we're all trying to figure out what's
the best way forward you know the next
two to three weeks are gonna tell us a
lot they're gonna tell us if the health
care system completely collapses they're
going to tell us if you know probably if
we're heading into more of a severe
lockdown something that looks or not
that looks it is a martial law these
things are all on the table I don't know
that we have to freak out about them so
you don't really have control over them
but the idea of you know the election
getting pushed back or being canceled
the idea that you know come November
people are not going to be able or feel
comfortable voting getting the other you
know all of these things are gonna
change our lives for a foreseeable
period it's not conspiracy mongering to
say that we are you know in you know the
survival of the country right now is not
guaranteed and I and I don't I don't say
that you know to joke around and I don't
say that
to be dramatic or to be an alarmist the
survival of the country that we are
living in right now
in any and by the way the country in the
sense that it looks or feels like
anything you remember it's not
guaranteed it's not it's truly not and
the people at the top know that we're at
the precipice of something very very
challenging and if you see huge spikes
in crime if you see a global depression
if you see a loss of faith in the
government which I don't know how you
don't see more of I think it's because
people are afraid right now so they're
kind of ignoring certain things the
insider trading and stuff like that I
think people are you know you know
burying their heads in the sand but if
you see those things happen I mean this
these are the ingredients that you know
bring about a fall and we see that and
I'm hoping that doesn't happen and I'm
hoping that we're able to weather it but
it is not at all irresponsible to float
those possibilities because they are
real possibilities or real possibility
that your city and local governments
collapse because of this and that the
federal government then rolls in the
tanks and you don't have anymore rights
and it's not the America that you
remembered and the rich go to planned
communities where they have rights and
you don't and they have the technology
and they are able to weather the storm
for however long it is you know and you
you know sitting there in a Perkins you
know or a Denny's or Pizza Hut are not
going to weather the storm because you
are going to be left to unfortunately
perish by the people that you put so
much faith in and what will prevent that
bonds with your family with your friends
when the time comes you know not right
now but when the time comes probably
there will be you know I mean it will be
some time for fun I can't believe I'm
even saying this but it's like there
might be some type of organized
resistance to what happens I don't know
you know I you know it's funny because
it's not you know we have to laugh at
these things I mean we are laughing at
them but no if rich powerful people
leave us all to die you know you might
have to go and visit them I don't know
I'm just saying I am NOT you know I am
NOT trying to sound the alarm here other
than to say if you aren't going over
these possibilities you know ahead what
is happening in your head what is
happening in your head I'd love to know
I mean if you're not going over the real
possibility that these people are gonna
pull the ladder up I don't know what is
it the ladder up is that the expression
yeah yeah I don't know what you think is
happening I don't know what you imagine
it's gonna happen
you better hope chloroquine on works you
better hope REM Deseret works and this
might be as Rogan said the other day it
might be a dress rehearsal because the
next pandemic oh you know but maybe
maybe we'll be prepared probably not um
I'm gonna be the Hollywood improv this
weekend headlining fuck'em we're gonna
do it we're gonna do it took off minimum
haha but those are the hack jokes that
are going on on Instagram right yeah
where people should be taken out and
shot
so I mean be careful the content you put
out be careful the content you consume
you know you know I I wonder how it's
all gonna play out it's very interesting
I you know the one thing that'll save us
is literally what I believe this is
truly what I believe I think the one
thing that saves us is that the robots
are not good enough yet if the robots
could do all the things these people
wanted Oh goodbye I mean truly if AI and
automation like if AI was at the point
where the AI could do most of what the
wealthy needed done I would be like in
total panic mode I think that we're
still some years from that happening
that might be the only thing that saves
us
it's not about democrat or republican
it's not about any of that
it's about this is just a strong survive
in innocence it's just Darwinian and
that's what you're seeing right now is
you're seeing nature you know it was
Chris Hedges said the other day we're in
the middle of the six extinction or
whatever this was a year before this
even happened so I mean I'm not don't
don't be too anxious don't be too
depressed
don't use too many mind-altering
substances stay sober keep your mind
sharp you're going to need it I'm hoping
the worst doesn't happen I'm cautiously
optimistic only because robots cannot do
all of the jobs yet I don't I don't
think it's you know it's like I don't I
don't I don't I'm not trading on empathy
here I'm like thank God we're a little
behind
um but you know keep your wits about you
out there it's it's it's not gonna be
pretty
and uh we appreciate you listening you
know reality really caught up with this
show really dead and one of the reasons
that the show's always kind of been
darker is not because I'm some profit or
I know you're like I you know I didn't I
don't live in that headspace all the
time I'm funny and I but when you look
around society I always saw it as
somewhat fragile and I think other
people didn't I think that's what it
comes down to I always looked at the
institutions of society
they were the fools that were running
the show and I always said to myself
these are fragile institutions it really
wouldn't take much and now you're kind
of seeing that this is how that
manifests when you're led by sociopaths
and clowns and goons and people that
just really want money and power and
they just enrich themselves and there's
no checks on them and there there's no
democratic process that [ __ ] means
anything and everything is you know
being sold to the highest bidder and
everything's about the consolidation of
power and it's a you know a partnership
of the public and the private sector
that's the you know corporate state as
hedges and other people have said when
it gets so all powerful I mean you look
at it and you go yeah this is something
that's just so corrupt so incompetent
and yet also very ruthless you know and
it lacks any empathy ah you look at a
society that's like that and you go yeah
there's the potential here for some real
problems and we have children licking
toilet seats on Plains I mean this is
where we're at it's not a you know I'm
not making that up this is there are
people licking the toilet seats on
planes because they're treating this as
a joke it's a profoundly disturbed
Society I read today there's kids
coughing on fruit as a joke in the store
it's a profoundly sick and disturbed
Society and I if you don't believe that
please point me to the evidence please
show me the evidence cuz I got a lot I
got exhibit ABCDE the whole alphabet so
show me your evidence when we have kids
licking the toilet seats on planes
tell me by the way [ __ ] the pandemic
[ __ ] it they're gonna get a pandemic
or that they're making their you know
that they're putting old people at risk
or that their self
forget all about that what if they were
just licking the toilet seats on Plains
how about that let's ignore the social
context what if kids young people young
adults were licking the toilet seats on
an airliner and putting it on social
media and you're telling me we are not a
profoundly these are the people that was
pointed out by Whitney Cummings the
other day on her podcast that last year
we're eating Tide Pods they were eating
soap because they liked the colors and
how it felt in their mouth and you're
telling me we are not a profoundly sick
and disturbed society they're eating
soap and now they're licking the turlet
and this is the future okay I feel bad
for coronavirus that has to infest us
hopefully we [ __ ] get ahead and beat
this thing I really really really want
life to go back to the way it was but
there's unmasks the whole thing if
you're [ __ ] thinking if you're
looking around and how people are
responding to this how fragile it all is
this unmasks the whole thing if you're
[ __ ] awake you see how unsustainable
our lives are not only the systems which
we've created but how unsustainable our
beliefs are the idea that we're safe and
the people that know more than us are
figuring things out on our behalf is not
the case it's not the case now I
coronavirus tried to buy an ad on this
show and I declined you know I was
contacted by somebody who said Corona
wants advertisers on the show Cove at 19
to advertise because they think they're
getting a bad rap in the media and
because if anyone would understand
population control it's your listeners
so kovat wants to come up and kind of
just talk for a little bit no like you
want to interview covered I'm like not
really not really um but good luck out
there folks it's gonna be a fun couple
of months we're putting out as much free
content as we can hope you and your
family are safe really try to get out
there and you know but take some time to
read some books read some books how do
we get here read the devil's chessboard
David Talbott read family secrets respec
read other things read tragedy and hope
carroll quigley
history of you know the world in our
time read harlots ghost by Norman male
or any of these things you know read
books like sapiens read other things
read books that I don't even know you
know read books that about biology and
epidemiology I don't know but you know
figure out how we got here figure out
how most of our social media feeds are
clogged up between the game show host
mr. Trump and a bartender Misco Cortez
and how those two people we've decided
that they are going to be our avatars
they are going to be the people that
speak on our behalf
how do we get here how did that happen
how did it happen it's not an accident
didn't happen by accident it's a long
process of kind of giving up little by
little little by little taking the hand
off the wheel and just cruising and
hosting and this is where it leads you
this is where it leads you when you just
take your your foot off the gas and you
just let it go this is where you end up
so when you have the time go and do a
little reading and figure out exactly
how and then read about other empires
and how they fell and you start to go oh
wow this sounds familiar
you know everybody's obsessed with Saxon
food you know they make celebrities out
of chefs I mean read about the four
Rome it's [ __ ] wild you know so again
hopefully we make it over this hurdle
hopefully I'm somewhat I'm somewhat in
the middle I know no good could be good
could be you know Lord of the Flies we
don't know we know now but if we do we
could look forward to coronavirus the
musical we could look forward to so many
shitty movies we could look forward to a
bangin Netflix doc kids in ten years be
smoking weed in the dorms watching a
bang and documentary about Cove in
nineteen you know if there are dorms and
if there are kids good luck